this morning our series the dish brings
you a taste of naples italy by way of
new york city una pizza napolitana is
one of the most well-reviewed pizza
joints in america owner anthony mangieri
is both the mind and the muscle behind
the operation we spent the morning
getting inside his head and behind the
counter to talk inspiration passion and
humility as we discovered when it comes
to making the perfect pizza to mangieri
they are all connected
you have said that your relationship
with pizza
is like an addiction
to a drug please explain that to me
because to be honest i identify with
that that's how much i loved football i
think the addiction to the pizza is the
idea also that like i can never really
reach the finish line with it i feel
like the more i put into it the more
time i put into it the
further away i actually get from
the idea of mastering it
anthony mangieri talks about pizza the
way someone could describe the delicate
subtleties of falling in love
and to really understand where love like
that comes from
you need to understand its origin long
ago there wasn't really anyone in
america making the pizza that was from
naples and you know my family is from
that part of the world and i used to
drive my grandmother crazy and she was
more of the kind of woman like a lot of
old school people were they were just
like i don't want to talk about anything
leave me alone and i was like but i want
to know this and i want to know that and
then as i got older and started to go to
italy like it just
it connected with me so much it tasted
so different than like
anything i had eaten you know my
original goal was to like
bring this like
ethnic
almost exotic food to america una pizza
napoletana on new york's lower east side
is what you get after decades of
refining the simple
the menu
it's uncomplicated
only pizza here
five different pies and the ingredients
mangiare keeps that simple too
now can you explain to me how creating
something
so simple
can be so difficult you know when things
are really simple i think that's when it
actually can get complicated because
there's nothing to hide behind you know
it's almost like
if you're
you know in a rock band and you're going
to do your solo concert and it's going
to be like using an acoustic with nobody
else there's nowhere to hide it's
similar with making pizza and especially
the way we do it aruna which is like
pretty straightforward pretty lightly
topped and really trying to let the very
few ingredients that we use sing you can
get lost in that mangiari now 50 years
old discovered his pizza obsession while
in his teens he opened a bakery in new
jersey when he was 22 and established
the first una at the jersey shore in the
90s
he later moved that shop to manhattan
and then to san francisco before
settling back home here in new york city
our dough is the same way we've made it
since the beginning
it's naturally 11 so there's no yeast in
it what that means on some health sides
is that it's easier to digest
we change the dough mixture every day i
don't think we've ever made it really
exactly the same no and i don't write
anything down either so
some days we come in and we're like oh
my god it's great and some days we come
in and like even today i was like dear
god i hope it worked last night get down
splashed across the pages of high
profile restaurant reviews mangieri's
work has been widely recognized thank
you anthony here he is in the showtime
hit billion it's good to love what you
do enjoy guys and food critics of every
flavor have sampled and reviewed his
neapolitan style pizza pete wells of the
new york times said this about your
pizza
unmistakably the finest sit down pizza
in the five boroughs
does stuff like that go to your head
no no i mean man i feel so grateful like
to even be able to make pizza and do it
for a living actually i think when he
called me to fact check for that article
i was i pretty sure i said
you don't have to write about us
you know
it has to drive you though and i i know
you drive yourself yeah i was gonna say
i mean i'm pretty self-driven and
self-motivated
for more than a quarter century he's
made nearly every bit of dough and every
una pizza himself
this oven reaches temperatures around
1000 degrees it only takes about 90
seconds for a finished pizza to emerge
so you take one scoop like that one
little layer set it in the center and
kind of spin it around oh my god that
spoon and trust me it's harder than it
looks and you make pizza until you're
out of we make yeah we open at five we
make pizza til we're at a dough
along with our pizzas which we have five
very basic ones there's four toppings
that you can add to those
toppings are those toppings are
parmigiano-reggiano
calabria long hot peppers which are
amazing pepperoni but it's not your
average pepperoni it's incredible and
anchovy is from the amalfi coast
for mangiari quality product starts with
being open and being humble it's baked
into his personality and baked into his
pizza i don't think anything can stop
you it's like cause and effect yeah it's
the rules of the universe you know but
like you would know man playing sports
it's like
you know you're not gonna be an nfl
superstar
in five minutes like it's a lifetime of
like effort and struggle so the
mozzarella and it's the same with a
small business whatever it is if you
give it
people are gonna come in they're gonna
see it much respect to y'all it's just
tricky they're gonna get it they're
gonna understand that like this is for
real this is the truth we put it on here
yeah
and that like you are giving it your all
and i think it's undeniable and i think
you will find your success
man i could sit here all day long and
eat these pieces man thank you
and they brought us some pizza because i
know that's what we said where's the
pizza they're in the back oh okay i want
to go to anthony's house he's got such a
great face and i love his confidence
he's got swagger he does have swag well
he's been doing it a long time and he
approaches it from a place with passion
um which makes it easy for him to do his
job it trips me out that he has been
there every single step of the way yeah
so how do you feel about doing billions
oh he's i remember that episode nervous
he was nervous he was nervous for sure
more nervous to make a pizza but you
make pizza though tony i do i got an ooh
in my backyard new grill but i do make a
pizza all right we gotta come by your
house to eat